after the heaviest night of bombing this
place has ever experienced it is a
wonder jamal at nasia is still here
the family house had only recently been
built
it was home for the whole nacia family
30 of them lived here
everything is still here she says all
our new belongings
but now destroyed what will we do now
this whole neighborhood has been
destroyed but they still look for what
might be left
in a place where nowhere is safe the
hospitals give some
cover many spent the night here
but are told they must leave they're too
busy with the injured
this woman asks why again this is
happening to them
and then close by more
the israeli government says this level
of destruction is necessary in the
defense of the nation
2 500 rockets have been fired from gaza
at israeli communities since monday
night
more in a week than in years combined
before
and the israeli military has told sky
news that the purpose of all this
is to destroy a network of tunnels a
thousand kilometers of them
where militants hide with their weapons
the prime minister
remains defiant
we are reaching out to them everywhere
to all these people and we will continue
to do so
they attacked us on our holiday they
attacked our capital
they sent missiles to our city they are
paying
and they will pay a heavy price for it
it's not over yet
we will do everything to restore
security to our city
and our citizens but in the other
palestinian enclave the west bank
we saw how this week has stirred
something deep
with burning tyres for cover and with
rocks in slingshots young palestinians
said they were defending their land
the israeli soldiers hit back with live
rounds and with tear gas
dropped from a drone among the
protesters here a 27 year old who didn't
want to reveal his face
first of all i need to hide my face
because of my mom
if he sees me then she'll kill me not
the israelis
in the clashes was a moment to hear his
motivation
people who live in palestine know that
palestine
is is a big and a huge
jail cell basically we cannot move we
cannot do anything
so i think this is a normal reaction for
all the suppression
can you go to jerusalem and of course
not
i i've never been to jerusalem and it's
my dream to go there
mustafa baguti is a former minister in
the palestinian authority
what you see here is unity between
palestinians in the west bank in gaza
ship
in in the diaspora in jordan in lebanon
palestinians and lebanon have been
trying to enter the borders and come
here
and what you also see here is
unprecedented unity with palestinians
who live inside the israel in 1948 areas
the drive to the other west bank towns
takes you past jewish israeli
settlements
which have this year expanded at an
unprecedented pace
and passed israel's security barrier a
wall and offense
the length of the enclave in bethlehem
the israeli military passed through the
wall and fired tear gas at the
protesters
but it is the clashes within mixed towns
in israel itself which has caused the
most surprise
this is kawakama in the galilee
the israeli military is stretched across
the country
back in gaza the united nations school
is another place they hope will provide
some safety
but in such a densely packed place with
no way of leaving
this is gaza today mark stone sky news
in israel